FLOUNDERING CAMPAIGN FOR
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR.
>> WE ARE AT A TURNING POINT
RIGHT NOW.
HERE AND AROUND THE WORLD.
BECAUSE THERE A POLITICS OF
MEANNESS AND THE VISION AND
CONFLICT.
OF TRIBALISM AND CYNICISM.
STEVE: HE IS AGAINST MEANNESS
AND DIVISION IN CONFLICT AND
TRIBALISM AND CYNICISM SO WHY
DID HE SAY THIS IN THE SAME
SPEECH?
>> WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO BE
WASTING ON THESE SON PHONY
TRUMPED UP CULTURE WARS TO
FAKE OUTRAGE THE RIGHT WING
MEDIA HAS DONE TO RAISE THE
READINGS THE FATHER PROTESTERS
DAUGHTER SCHOOL COVERING OF
THE FACT SHE WAS RAPED IN THE
BATHROOM AND THOSE BUREAUCRATS
THAT COVERED UP THE DAUGHTER
AS A FATHER WHOSE DAUGHTER WAS
RAPED NOW PORTRAYED AS A
RACIST THEN USED TO SMEAR
APPEARANCE RIGHTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAS DOMESTIC TERRORIST
WHICH IN TURN IS USED BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO THREATEN
PARENTS TO PROTEST
INDOCTRINATION IN THEIR
SCHOOLS WITH THE FBI ALL BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HIS
FAMILY IS PROFITING FROM THE
EXACT SAME INDOCTRINATION
APPEARANCE ARE PROTESTING AND
THE CALL THAT FAKE OUTRAGE
CALLS IT TRIBALISM AND
CYNICISM?
IF THERE IS A WORSE EXAMPLE OF
ALL OF THOSE THINGS BY THAT
SPEECH THEN OBAMA LET US KNOW
WHERE IT IS.
I LIKE OBAMA I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE FAIR SO I WILL
SAY THIS IS OBVIOUS THAT OBAMA
IS A DEVOTED FATHER AND FAMILY
MAN IN THAT RESPECT A GREAT
ROLE MODEL.
WHAT WAS SHE HAD DONE OR SAID
IF IT WAS ONE OF HIS DAUGHTERS
RAPED AT SCHOOL AND THE SCHOOL
COVERED IT UP?
THE RAPE OF A CHILD AND HE
CALLED THAT FAKE OUTRAGE THAT
IS NOT JUST A FAKE OUTRAGE BUT
OBSCENITY HE DARED TO
CRITICIZE REPUBLICANS FOR
BEING MEAN?
I AM DONE WITH THESE DEMOCRATS
PATHOLOGICAL HYPOCRISY.
HATE AND DIVISION FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO PLAY THE RACE CARD
AT EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
NO MORE LECTURES ON
MISINFORMATION.
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS EQUALS
ZERO.
NO MORE LECTURES ON COMPASSION
FROM THE PEOPLE WHO
INCENTIVIZE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
NO MORE LECTURES ON SAVING
DEMOCRACY FROM THE PEOPLE WHO
PUSH BALLOT HARVESTING ON
GERRYMANDERING FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO JUST CARVED UP THE
ILLINOIS CONGRESSIONAL MAP TO
SAVE THEIR SEATS NO MORE
LECTURES ON CLIMATE THE PEOPLE
TO BAKE ALL PACKAGES MORE OIL
NO MORE LECTURES ON THE DEBT
LIMIT FROM THE PEOPLE WHO
VOTED AGAINST RAISING IT TIME
AFTER TIME AFTER TIME.
NO MORE LECTURES.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DIVIDING
AMERICA.
THEY ARE PUSHING HATEFUL
POLI